>> AWESOME, THANKS, CHIEF.
I WILL TAKE IT FROM HERE.
ALREADY, THANKS.
I HAVE THE PLEASURE TO HELP
MODERATE THIS PANEL TODAY.
LET'S SBRE DEUCE THE PLAYERS TO
YOU.
FIRST UP, WE HAVE KATHERINE, GM
OF PRODUCT STRATEGY.
WE HAVE JASON, RACHEL CARD.
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT AND ROUNDING THINGS
OUT IS CHRIS NOVAK, PARTNER AND
HEAD OF XBOX DESIGN STUDIO.
EVERYONE, WELCOME.
COOL.
CAN WE HEAR EVERYBODY?
YOU ON THE PHONE?
>> HELLO.
>> WE'RE HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US.
>> HEY, BRIAN.
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
WE GOT A COUPLE GROUND RULES
TODAY.
AGAIN, WE ARE DOING IT LIVE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
FUN.
EVERYBODY THAT IS GOING TO BE BE
ON PICTURE AND NO VIDEO, WE WILL
DO LITTLE BIT OF LISTENING
ACTIONS.
I WILL ASK QUIS AND I WILL TRY
TO ASK A QUESTION DIRECTLY TO A
PERSON.
JUST GIVE A SECOND PAUSE SO WE
MAKE SURE WE ARE NOT SPEAKING
OVER EACH OTHER.pWITH THAT, BEF
MEAT OF THE TOPICS, I WANT TO
GIVE CONTEXT TO EACH OF YOU
CHOSEN HERE TODAY.
KATHERINE, BEFORE X CLOUD, YOU
STILLED AS PHIL SPENCER'S CHIEF
OF STAFF AND BRINGS MORE THAN 20
YARS OF PRODUCT EXPERIENCE.
HOW HAS IT PREPARED TO YOU STEP
IN THE LEADERSHIP ROLE?
>> SO FIRSTLY, BRIAN, I JUST
WANT TO SAY I WISH I COULD BE
THERE IN PERSON.
ALL OUR WORLDS ARE TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN BY THIS CRAZY VIRUS.
AND IN FACT, I GOT TWO KIDS IN
ANOTHER ROOM DOING HOME
SCHOOLING AND MY HUSBAND ON
MEETINGS ELSEWHERE.
SO JUST FINGERS CROSSED MY
INTERNET WILL STAND UP.
WHAT PREPARED ME FOR THIS ROLE.
REALLY, I SPENT THE LAST 20
YEARS BUILDING A CAREER TO
HARNESS TECHNOLOGY AND BUSINESS
MODELS FOR CONTENT AND THREE
YEARS AGO I JOINED XBOX AS PHIL
SPENCER'S CHIEF OF OF STAFF.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE EXFEERNS.
SO LEARN ABOUT GAMING ALONGSIDE
HIM, JUST GAVE ME INSIGHT INTO
WHERE THE BUSINESS IS GOING YOU
KNOW WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
LOOKING FOR THE STRATEGY IN THAT
PERIOD.
WHERE WE STARTED OUR GOAL WAS TO
REACH THE 2 BILLION GAMERS ON
THE PLANET.
WE DESIGNED OUR FRAME WORK AS
THE CONTENT COMMUNITY, AND
CLOUD.
AND YOU KNOW, AS YOU CAN SEE,
I'M LUCKY ENOUGH NOW TO GET TO
EXECUTE THIS STRATEGY WITH AN
AMAZING TEAM.
YOU KNOW, REALLY GET E E TO
EXECUTE ON THIRD SEED, THE CLOUD
STRATEGY.
SO COULDN'T FEEL LUCKIER.
>> AWESOME.
AWESOME.
LET'S GO TO YOU.
YOU ARE PART OF THE CORE TEAM ON
XBOX SERIES X.
BEFORE THAT, THE KPX BOX GAME
STUDIOS.
HUH A FRONT ROW SEAT TO THE
EVOLUTION IN THE INDUSTRY.
HOW DOES IT INFLINS UENCE THE W
YOU LEAD TEAMS?
>> THANKS, BRIAN, REALLY, THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
TIMES IN THE LONG HISTORY OF THE
GAME.
AND THE TECHNOLOGIES AND GAME
DESIGN AND NEW WAYS TO ENGAGE
WITH PLAYERS.
I THINK WE LISTEN TO THE
CUSTOMERS AND IT SHAPES WHERE WE
TAKE THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
PLATFORMS WE DELIVER.
AND AS A PLATFORM BUILD
INTERDESIGNER, THE ROLE IS TO
EMPOWER DEVELOPERS ON THE
CREATIVE VISIONS AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE BEST HARDWARE,
SOFTWARE AND DEVELOP TOOLS.
WE WANT THE TECHNOLOGY TO FADE
AWAY FOR DEVELOPERS AND PLAYERS
SO THE GAMERS HAVE THE MOST
AMAZING AND IMHER MERSIVE
EXPERIENCE.
>> RACHEL, YOU WORKED WITH WITH
THE GOVERNOR OF SOUTH CAROLINA
AND LED AN INDY GAME STUDIO.
HOW HAS YOUR BACKGROUND GIVING
YOU SUCCESS FOR XBOX SERIES X.
>> BRIAN, THANKS FOR THAT.
I HAVE A REALLY UNIQUE
BACKGROUND, AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, I FEEL VERY, VERY
FORTUNATE FOR THE EXPERIENCES I
HAD IN EDUCATION AND IN MY
PROFESSIONAL ROLES.
THE RED THREAD, I HAD AN HONOR
TO WORK WITH REALLY GREAT PEOPLE
AND DO GREAT THINGS.
AND IN THE GAME STUDIO, WE
PERFORMED IT, ET WAS REALLY
ABOUT BUILDING AMAZING
EXPERIENCES FOR GAMERSES AND
REALLY DIGGING DEEP TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WOULD DELIGHT
THEM.
AND THE SKILLS I BRING WITH ME.
WHEN I WORKED WITH THE GOVERNOR,
IT WAS AN AWESOME EXPERIENCE.
WE WERE A MISSION TO INCREASE
JOB STUDENTS AND HELP A
DIFFICULT EDUCATION SYSTEM AND A
CURRENT ROYAL NOW, MICROSOFT,
IT'S A MISSION TO DRIVE TO
EMPOWER EVERY PERSON AND
ORGANIZATION ON THE PLANET.
AND WE ARE IN A POSITION TO DO
THAT.
FOR ME, WHEN I THINK ABOUT
PRODUCT, I'M GRATEFUL FOR MY
EXPERIENCES AND I'M MOST
GRATEFUL FOR MY TEAM
EXPERIENCES.
I THINK WE ALL HAVE INDIVIDUAL
EWE
UNIQUE EXPERIENCES THAT SHAPE
THE PRODUCTS WE BUILD.
WE BELIEVE HAD THAT IN OUR CORE.
>> THAT IS GOOD.
CHRIS, LET'S GO TO YOU QUICK.
YOU ARE A GAME DESIGNER BY
TRADE.
AND 25 YEARS EXPERIENCE.
AND MOTORSPORTS, AND PROJECT
GO
GOT
GOTHOM.
WOULD YOU MIND E LLABORATING A
LITTLE BIT?
>> YEAR, SURE, HAPPY TO.
THERE ARE TWO HOLES.
ONE IS FOR CUSTOMER, THAT IS TO
PURELY HELP GALVANIZE A TEAM AND
DELIVER SOMETHING THAT IS
UNEXPECTEDLY FUN AND I USE THE
TERM -- AND WHEN YOU'RE IN AN
ENTERTAIN INDUSTRY AND YOU MAKE
A GAME OR PLAY THE GAME, IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING TO, YOU KNOW,
BEAT THE EXPECTATION THAT
SOMEBODY HAS WHEN THEY EXPECT IT
TO BE FUN.
YOU ARE REALLY TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT DELIVERS THAT
LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA FUN THAT
MAKES PEOPLE TALK.
AND THEY DID WHAT?
I COULDN'T EXPECT IT.
I NEED E TO TRY THAT OUT AND
IT'S THE LAST LITTLE BIT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO DRIVE A
FERRARI, YOU EXPECT THE IT TO BE
FAST AND YOU DO NOT EXPECT THE
GUY NEXT TO YOU TO HIT A BUTTON
THAT HITS A BOOSTER ROCKET.
YOU WERE NOT EXPECTING IT AND
THE BOOSTER ROCKET IS WHAT TOOK
IT OVER THE TOP.
THAT IS WHAT YOU TRY DO IN THE
GAME.
AND TRY TO TAKE THE PLAYER ON A
JOURNEY AND FEEL SOMETHING.
THE SECOND ROLE, REALLY, THE
TEAM, IT'S REALLY REGARDED AS
THE DISCIPLINE THAT HELPS TIE
EVERYTHING TOGETHER IN SOMETHING
PURE.
SOMETHING VERY FOCUSED.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN HEY, THERE
MIGHT BE BUSINESS QUESTIONS AT
HAND OR TECH QUESTIONS AND
DESIGNERS ARE REALLY THE ONE
WITHES -- PINNED TO HEY, HERE IS
WHERE THIS CAN GO, AND HERE IS
THAT VISION, AND WHAT IT DIDN'T
THE GO RIGHT AND STILL DELIVER
KURS HER EXPERIENCE.
AND THERE IS A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT FLAVORS, YOUR JOB IS
TO DELIVER SOMETHING FOCUSED,
FUR AND TAKES THE PLAYER ON A
JOURNEY AND MAKES THEM FEEL
SOMETHING.
>> THAT IS GOOD.
I FEEL LIKE WHEN I SEE A DESIGN,
WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ALL
THE TIME IN THE OFFICE, CHRIS,
GOOD PRODUCTS START WITH GOOD
DESIGN.
I LOVE HAVING YOU ON THE PANEL.
LET'S GET STARTED AND GET AT IT.
WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS.
JASON, THERE WAS BIG NEWS
WEEK ON XBOX SERIES X.
CAN YOU TO TELL US HOW THE
TECHNICALED A VANTSS ALLOW THEM
TO HAVE NOW EXPERIENCES.
>> THIS IS A REALLY EXCITING
WEEK FOR THE TEAM.
THE TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING HARD
AND FINALLY TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
SOME OF THE DETAILS, HAS BEEN A
HIGHLIGHT FOR ALL OF US.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED, YOU SHARED
MANY OF THE DETAILS OF THE NEXT
GENERATION CONSOLE AND IT'S
REALLY THE EXPERIENCES WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN IN THE LIVING ROOM.
IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS, THE DESIGN OF
THE XBOX SERIES X IS REALLY
DIRECTLY INFLUENCED BY THREE KEY
PRINCIPLES.
AND I MENTIONED BEFORE, FIRST
AND FOREMOST, DEVELOP INTERGAMER
FEEDBACK.
AND THE TEAM WORKED CLOSELY WITH
DEVELOPERS ACROSS THE WORLD
WORKING WITH EVERYTHING, THE
BLOCK BURSTERS AND COMPETITIVE
TITLES AND EXTREMELY INNOVATIVE
TITLES AND GAME DESIGN COMING
FROM THE BEST CREATORS AND WE
LISTENED, LEARNS, AND OVERCOME
THE TECHNOLOGY BARRIERS THAT WE
ARE LIMITING THE ASPIRATIONS FOR
THE GAMES THEY ARE CREATING,
WHETHER THAT IS IN HARDWARE,
SOFTWARE OR THE DEVELOPER TOOLS
THAT WE PROVIDE AND ANOTHER KEY
ASPECK, GAMERS ARE DEFIND
MANDING HIGHER AND STANDARD
FRAME RIGHTS, AND A SYSTEM THAT
CAN DELIVER THE GAME
EXPERIENCES, AND WE CHALLENGE
OURSELVES TO GO FURTHER AND TO
DELIVER FRAME RATES YOU NEVER
THOUGHT POSSIBLE IN THE LIVING
ROOM.
AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR.
AND THE SECOND ONE IS REALLY
LOOKING AT INNOVATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY, AND EVERYTHING FROM
ADVANCEMENTS IN PERFORMANCE, AND
MORE EFFICIENT USE OF GPU, NEXT
GENERATION GRAPHICS INNOVATION
AND CAPABILITIES, AND HARDWARE
STR
TRACING OR VARY ARABLE SHADING
AND GIVE THE DWOM TO SPEND TIME
IN, AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE, WE ARE
A THE UPPER BOUNDS OF WHAT IS
POSSIBLE AND THE TRADITIONAL
DRIVE TECHNOLOGY, IT WAS REALLY
CON TRAINING THE GAME DESIGN,
THE DEVELOPERS HAVING TO
ARBITRARILY FUNNEL PLAYERS
THROUGH DIFFERENT TUNNELS OR
PATH WAYS OR YOU HAVE A FAST
TRAVEL SYSTEM AND YOU TAKE A
LONG TIME TO TELEPORT FROM ONE
SIDE OF THE MAP TO THE OTHER,
AND THE SSD LEVEL PERFORMANCES
AND TO THE MAKE IT EASIER FOR
GAME DEVELOPERS AND TO STREAM
ASSETS IN REAL TIME FROM A
STORAGE SOLUTION IN THE MEMORY
AND THE CP SBURKS THE GPU SO YOU
CAN GET THE RIM DYNAMIC LIVING
WORD THAT PLAYERS EXPECT.
AND I THINK THE FINAL PRINCIPLE
OR THING THAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT,
IN THE EARLY DAYS, WAS WHEN YOU
DESIGN A NEW CONSOLE HARDWARE
PLATFORM, YOU SET THE DIRECTION
FOR GAMING AND GAMING
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE NEXT 7 TO 10
YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SOLID
DIVISION TO WHERE YOU SEE THE
GAME DEVELOPMENT GOING AND THE
GAME EXPERIENCE THAT PLAYERS
WANT TO HAVE.
AND WITH THE PROJECT X CLOUD, WE
KNEW WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT COULD OPEN UP BRAND NEW
POSSIBILITIES THAT DEVELOPERS
AND ONE THING WE LEARNED EARLY
ON, AS WE STARTED WORKING
SOME OF THE SAME CHALLENGES WE
HAD IN DEVELOPING THE
PERFORMANCE IN THE LIVING ROOM
IS THE SAME CHALLENGES WE HAVE
IN THE DATACENTER.
THINGS SUCH AS DELIVERING HIGH
PERFORMANCE FOR GAMING WORKLOADS
AND MININICING POWER CONSUMPTION
AND POWER MANSIONMAGEMENT.
AND HOW WE DESIGN THE POWER X
AND THE OVERALL SYSTEM
ARCHITECTURE SO WE MAKE SURE WE
ARE A HARDWARE, SOFTWARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PLATFORM TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO BRING THE GAMES TODAY
ON THE CONSOLE INTO THE CLOUD IN
THE FUTURE.
MANY OF THE TECHNOLOGIES WE ARE
INUP E K
INKNOW
INNOVATING AND WE BROUGHT TO THE
FUTURE WITH MIND FROM THE
OUTSIDE OF THE PROGRAM.
>> YEAH WITH, WOW.
>> THIS IS BLOWING MY MIND.
HAVING WORKED ON THE TEAM A
WHILE AND GETTING A CHANCE TO
SEE WHAT THIS THING LOOKS LIKE
IN PERSON IS KIND OF LIKE
SHOCKING RIGHT NOW.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME I -- I CAN'T
TOUCH IT.
MY FINGERPRINTS WILL GET ON IT.
I GEEK OUT ABOUT THIS ALL THE
TIME.
AND YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT
REALLY LAS JUST BLOWN MY MIND A
BIT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE
BUILT A CONSOLE THINKING ABOUT
THE NEXT GENERATION, THE NEXT
PARADIGM SHIFT AND YOU THINK
ABOUT THE CLOUD.
YOU CAN TOUCH ON THE ROLE THAT
THE CLOUD PLAYS, AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF XBOX SERIES X?
>> SURE.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE CERTAIN
SCENARIOS, THIS IS A CUSTOM SSC,
AN ARCHITECTURE WE DESIGNED FROM
THE GROUND UP TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE DELIVERING THE HIGH FIDELITY
GAMING EXPERIENCE AND THE CLOUD,
WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH PROJECT X
CLOUD, THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT FOR EXAMPLE VIRTUALIZING
THE CONTROLER, IF WE ARE JUST
DESIGNING A SYSTEM TO -- IN SUCH
A WAY TO MAKE A HIGH PERFORMING
GAMING CONSOLE IT'S A DESIGN
DECISION YOU COULDN'T THINK
ABOUT AND YOU REALLY ONLY GET
ONE CHANCE TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND IT'S WHEN YOU'RE
DESIGNING THE CHIP, THE SYSTEM,
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW
DEVELOPERS ARE GOING TO TAKE
THEIR GAMES AND MOVE THEM TO --
INTO THE CLOUD OR HOW THEY ARE
WILL GOING TO BE IN THE FUSM.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
DEVELOPERS DON'T HAVE TO
ACTUALLY GO IN AND ALTER THEIR
GAME OR REWRITE THEIR GAME FROM
SKRA
SCRATCH.
WE WANT TO FROM VID A PATH SO
IT'S ACCESSIBLE AND REALLY IT'S
ABOUT EMPOWERING DEVELOPERS TO
REACH CUSTOMER ACROSS THE WORLD.
AND STREAMING IS GOING TO BE
PRIMARY EXPERIENCE, WE WANT TO
PROVIDE THAT EASY PASS FOR
DWOMERS.
>> AND SOMETHING YOU SAID, I
HAVE ONE MORE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT -- A LOT OF TEENS, A LOT OF
PEOPLE MAY BE WATCHING PLAB JUST
DON'T KNOW.
THE LEAD TEAM THAT IT TAKES IN
ORDER TO PUT TOGETHER A CONSOLE.
CAN YOU TALK TO US ABOUT -- YOU
MENTIONED MAKING TECHNOLOGY
DECISIONS OF WHAT THE HARDWARE
IS GOING TO BE IN THE BOX.
IT'S NOT THE LIKE -- IT'S TWO
MONTHS FROM LAUNCH, LET'S PUT IT
IN THERE, THERE IS A WHOLE
PROCESS.
YOU CAN E ELABORATE ON SOME OF
THE WORK IT TAKES TO THINK
THROUGH WHERE THIS IS GOING TO
BE IN TIME.
>> SURE.
YOU KNOW, WE REALLY STARTED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF XBOX SERIES X IN
2016.
BEFORE WE EVER RELEASED THE XBOX
1X.
ON YOUR LEAD TIMES, IT'S MULL PL
YEARS OF INVESTIGATION AND TRY
TO FIGURE IT OUT AND THE GAMES
AND THE EXPERIENCES THAT HAVE
COME UP IN THE LAST TWO OR THREE
YEARS, AND REALLY THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PARTNERS,
AND THE BEST CREATORS, ACROSS
THE INDUSTRY, AND ALSO MAKING
SURE WE HAVE A CLEAR VISION OF
WHERE WE SEE GAMING GOING, AS
TEAM XBOX.
AND ONCE WITH AGAIN, OUR GOAL IS
TO GET -- KATHERINE MENTIONED,
REALLY REACHING OUT TO THE
GAMERS ACROSS THE WORLD.
IT'S REALLY HOW DO WE MAKE IT
S
ARIZOAS
EASY AS POSSIBLE SO THOSE OF YOU
GAMING ON CONSOLES KNOW AND LOVE
TODAY, AND DO IT IN SUCH A WAY
THAT MAKES IT EASY FOR
DEVELOPERS.
>> THAT IS GOOD.
I THINK IT'S A PERFECT SEGUE AS
WELL.
LET'S DIG IN THE NEXT BIT.
WE WANT TO TALK ACT PROJECT X
CLOUD.
KATHERINE, WILL YOU TALK ABOUT
MICROSOFT BRINGS IT IN MARKET
AND I WANT TO -- FOLLOW ME ON
THE CAMERA.
THIS IS GOING TO BE FUN.
I HAVE A SERVER BLADE OVER HERE
FROM PROJECT X CLOUD THAT I WAS
SO EXCITED WHEN WITH I HEARD IT
WAS GOING TO BE HERE, THIS IS AN
ACTUAL PROJECT X CLOUD SERVER
BLADE THAT IS IN THE FOOTPRINTS
OF AZURE AND IT IS SO COOL TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE GUTS OF THIS
THING.
BECAUSE, WOW, THE TECH THAT WENT
INTO THIS -- THE MAKING OF THIS
IS UNBELIEVABLY IMPRESSIVE.
BACK TO THE QUESTION, WALK US
THROUGH MICROSOFT'S APPROACH OF
BRINGS X CLOUD TO MARKET.
>> YEAH, NO, ABSOLUTELY.
BRITAIN, WHEN YOU TOOK OFF
THERE, I HAD NO IDEA WHERE YOU
WERE GOING.
I WAS LIKE WHERE IS HE GOING
NOW?
IN YOU ARE SEEING OUR BLADE.
IT IS SO COOL AND IT IS --
RACHEL SAID IT EARLIERIER, AND I
COULD BEHIND MORE PROUD.
GOING BACK TO THE JOURNEY, THE
VERY BEGINNING OF A MULTIYEAR
JOURNEY WITH STREAMING.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS MUCH MORE WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT STREAMING THAN
WE DO KNOW RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHY WE CAME
TO MARKET WITH OUR PREVIEW PLAN.
WHERE WE -- YOU REMEMBER, IT
SEEMS LIKE AN AGE AGO NOW, WE
STARTED LAST OCTOBER WITH JUST
FOUR GAMES IN PREVIEW.
AND SINCE THEN, WE HAVE EXPANDED
COUNTRIES.
MORE THAN 90 GAMES.
WE HAVE ANDRADE AND AN IOS AND
WE ALSO BRING IT TO INWOES 10
PCs.
THIS REALLY ABOUT A JOURNEY OF
LEARNING TOGETHER WITH A DWOMER
COMMUNITY AND TO SEE THE PASSION
THEY HAVE LEANED INTO IT WITH US
AND THE LEERN LENNINGS WE ARE
DOING IS MIND GOING.
IT MAKES ME SO PROUD PO BE A
PART OF THE TEAM.
>> YOU MENTIONED JUST A MOMENT
AGO THE RESPONSE FROM SOME OF
THE GAME DEVELOPMENT COMMUNEDY.
YOU CAN SHARE, HOW HAS IT BE?
WHAT THAT I HAVE BEEN SAYING AND
BUILDING FOR PROJECT X CLOUD?
>> YEAH, NO, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, I'M REMINDED ACTUALLY
BACK TO A STORY -- WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TALKING WITH THE
DEVELOPERS BEFORE WE LAUNCHED
INTO PREVIEW.
AND EVERY TIME WE WOULD GO TO A
MEETING WITH A DEVELOPER, WE
WOULD TAKE THE GAME RUNNING ON A
MOBILE PHONE AND HAND IT TO THEM
TO PLAY, AND AT THAT POINT,
THERE WAS ALWAYS SILENCE IN THE
ROOM, AND WE LOOK AND THINK,
WHAT IS GOING ON?
AND THEN IT -- IT STARTS TO LOOK
AROUND THE ROOM AND TALKING TO
THE -- TO THE TEAMS AND SAYING,
WHO WORKED ON THIS THIS?
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT KNOWN
ONE HAD WORKED ON IT.
WHEN YOU BUILD FOR XBOX, YOU
BUILD FOR X CLOUD AND WE HAD
MADE THE GAME WORK AUTOMATICALLY
FOR THEM, AND IN A MATTER OF
MINUTES AND THE FIRST STAGE, WE
CALL LIFT AND SHIFT, TAKING A
GAME YOU BUILT FOR XBOX AND
PUTTING ANY THE CLOUD LITERALLY
BLEW THE DEVELOPERS AWAY.
SO THAT'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY
FASCINATING.
AND THEN WE JUST LEARNED, YOU
KNOW, SO MUCH ABOUT HOW GAMERS
ARE USING STREAMING AND
BASICALLY, WE ARE SEEING GAMERS
PLAY MORE ACROSS THE BOARD.
FASCINATING FOR DEVELOPERS.
THEY ARE NOT JUST PLAYING ON KX
CLOUD.
THEY ARE ALSO PLAYING ON XBOX
AND PC.
IT'S REALLY A JOURNEY OF US
LEARNING TOGETHER.
BUT WE ALSO AN AWARE THERE ARE
SOME DEVELOPERS WHO WANT TO BE
DOING MORE TO OPTIMIZE THEIR
GAMES FOR THE CLOUD.
AND IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES, WE
REALLY TALK ABAN IT AS CLOUD
AWARE TO SUPPORT INTERACTION AND
THE APIs THAT PROVIDE THE
CHARACTERISTICS TO THEY CAN
OPTIMIZE FOR A SMALLER SCREEN
SIZE.
YOU CAN SEE IT'S LIT RALLY A
JOURNEY THAT WE ARE ON WITH OUR
DEVELOPERS TO REALLY BEGIN TO
OPTIMIZE THIS EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I TALKED TO MY
TEAM, I REALLY TALK ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE SPEED OF OUR LEARNING
CYCLES.
WHEN YOU BRING A NEW TECHNOLOGY
TO MARK, IT'S ALL ABOUT LEARNING
AND THE FASTER WE LEARN, THE
BETTER WE ARE GOING TO OPTIMIZE
THE PRODUCT.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY THE JOURN NE
WE ARE.
>> AND ONE OF THE THINGS, WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO KEEP LEARNING AND
IMPROVING.
THAT IS REALLY AN EETHOS THAT YU
HELPED WITH THE TEAM.
AND CHRIS, OVER TO YOU, AN AS A
SERVICE AND PLATFORM PROVIDER,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
MICROSOFT'S NEW ROLL IS TO
NAVIGATE KPARKS BOX SERIES X AND
X CLOUD?
>> TWO WARDS, IT'S ELIMINATING
FRICTION.
GAME TEAMS HAVE A VISION FOR
WHAT THEY WANT TO BUILD AND
JOB IS TO LET THEM JUST EXECUTE
ON IT AND MULTIFLPLY THE EFFORT
AGAINST IT.
AND THERE ARE TIMES, THE TRICK
IS TO MANAGE WHEN YOU'RE A
STUDIO, LARGE OR SMALL.
AND SPLIMS BUSINESS QUESTIONS
COME UP AND YOU WANT TOO SELL
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND
THE PUBLISHER DOESN'T SUPPORT
THAT.
IT'S HOW DO YOU PUSH THAT AND
WORK WITH THE PUBLISHER TO GET
IT IN A COUPLE WAY MMPS
SOMETIMES IT'S TECHNOLOGY.
THERE IS A NEW TECH.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
WE WANT TO YOU PUSH IT FARTHER.-
WHEN I THINK ABOUT X CLOUD AND
THE SERIES X, MORE THAN THE GPU,
A GAME DESIGNER, THE DESIGN YOU
CAN BUILD BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
POWERFUL CPU IS SUPER
INTERESTING.
THAT IS -- YOU KNOW, FOR A WHILE
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
GRAPHICS AND WORLDS THAT LOOK
VERY REAL BUT THE CHALLENGE
FRANKLY FROM A GAME LOOP FROM A
GAME DYNAMIC, IS HOW DO YOU MAKE
THE WORLDS ACT REAL.
REAL?
PHYSICS AND DOING ALL THAT MATH
TUELLY REQUIRES A CPU THAT IS
PRETTY STRONG.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE TICK
THE STRTRADE OFFS HUH IN THE PA
AND A SMALL NUMBER OF ENEMIES
THAT ARE REALLY, REALLY SMART OR
A LAUNCH NUMBER THAT ARE NOT SO
SMART, YOU KNOW, WELL, GRUNTS,
THAT IS ALWAYS BEEN A TRADE OFF
THAT IS LIMITED WHAT YOU CAN DO
IN THE GAMES AND FROM THE -- THE
FASTEST THING TO MAKE A
DEVELOPER LAUGH IS YOU GO IN A
ROOM AND YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF
ENNYS AND EVERYTHING REACTS
LIKE, YEAH, WE CAN'T DO THE
PHYSICS FOR THAT.
YOU NEED A CPU WITH POWER TO DO
THAT.
SO, MOVING FORWARD ON SOMETHING
LIKE THE CLOUD, AND
UNDERSTANDING HEY, THIS ISN'T
JUST GOING TO BE SPLG WHERE IT'S
GOING TO LOOK MUCH BETTER.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE THAT WORLD
FEEL AND SOUND MUCH MORE REAL.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW TO YOU DO
BETTER THINGS WITH PHYSICS, LIKE
SIMULATIONS, THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WILL ALLOW GAMES TO
TAKE A GIANT STEP FORWARD.
AND AS A PUBLISHER, THERE IS A -
BREAD AND BUTTER WORK WE DO AND
HELPING PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING THE
RESEARCH WE HAVE DONE IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS AND UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE THINK THE TECHNOLOGY IS
GOING, AND THE SHELL EXPERIENCES
WE ARE GOING TO BUILDS THAT ARE
BASICALLY THE STAGE FOR THE
TITLE.
LIKE, THEY ARE BUILDING THIS
PEARL AND WE'RE THIS OYSTER TO
SHOW E CASE THAT PEARL AND
REALLY, THE PUBLISHER JOB IS HOW
DO YOU ELIMINATE DIRECTION TO
THE GAME TEAMS CAN JUST RUN AT
WHAT THEY ARE GOOD AT AND HELP
THEM SUPPORT WHERE THINGS THEY
HAVEN'T HAD TO CARE ABOUT.
BUILDING TOOLS TO ALLOW THEM TO
LOOK AT HOW THAT OPTIMIZE THEIR
ENGINE AND THAT IS -- SHOULDN'T
BE THEIR JOB.
AND DATACENTERS THIS SHOULD BE
OUR JOB.
WE CAN GO DO THAT.
THEY SHOULD FOCUS ON THE GAME
IT EASY YES TO TURN THINGS UP?E-
>> THAT IS GOOD.
AND YOU MENTION AS YOU ARE
TALKING THROUGH IT, THE IDEA OF
AWARENESS.
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO HAVE YOUR
GAME BE AWARE AND THE IDEA OF
STREAMING AWARE POINT OF VIEW.
JASON, YOU CAN ELABORATE ON WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE STREAMING AWARE,
BUILDING STREAMING AWARE?
>> YEAH SO LIKE KATHERINE IS
CHECKING AB, TODAY WITH PROJECT
X CLOUD, WE ARE DOING WHAT WE
CALL LIFT AND SHIFT, TAKING
GAMES WE ARE DESIGNS AND BUILT
FOR XBOX TO ONE THEM IN THE
CLOUD WITH THE TITLE NOT BEING
AWARE THAT IT'S RUNNING IN A
REMOTE DATA CENTER.
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF POWER AND
THERE IS A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY IF
THE TITLE ACTUALLY E KNOWS
WLMPBT IT'S -- WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S BEING STREAMED OR NOT.
AND WE ENABLE AED, TODAY, THE
SAME TECHNOLOGY.
IF YOU ARE ACTUALLY STREAMING
ARE FROM YOUR LOCAL CONSOLE OR
STREAMING FROM PROJECT X CLOUD,
WHAT WOULD YOU CHANGE IN YOUR
GAME?
AND KATHERINE USED, IF IT'S
STREAMING DOWN TO THE MOBILE
DEVICE, MAYBE I DESIGN MY HOOD
OR A UI FOR A TEN-FOOT USER
EXPERIENCE ON A LARGE SCREEN
TESTIFY TV AND WHEN I STREAM TO
A MOBILE DEVICE, I NEED TO
SIMPLIFY OR INCREASE THE FONT
SIDE SO IT'S MORE LEGIBLE AND
EASIER TO READ.
YOU THINK ABOUT SITUATIONS LIKE
MULTIPLAYER.
AND MULTIPLAYER SIMILARS ARE
DESIGNED WITH NETWORK LATENCY
AND HOW YOU KEEP PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
IF YOU RUNNING IN THE SAME
DATACENTER, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT PING TIMES OR
NETWORK LATENCY.
AND ONE OF THE TECHNOLOGIES WE
ANNOUNCED EARLIER THIS WEEK IS
DYNAMIC LAY TANSY INPUT.
OR DNI.
WE BUILD THAT SO WE HAVE MOST
RESIS AND RESPONSIVE INPUT
POSSIBLE.
IF YOU ARE PLAYING YOUR GAME IN
YOUR LIVING ROOM, AND THE SPORTS
GAME OR A GAME THAT IS RUNNING
120 GAMES A PERFECT, AND IT
REALLY MATTERS, AND THE SAME
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ALLOW A DEVELOPERS DEVELOPENT
AND THEY CAN UP OPT NICE OR
CUSTOMIZE THE INBUT EXPERIENCE
WHEN THEY ARE ACTUALLY STREAMING
TO A MOBILE DEVICE VERSUS WHEN
YOU HAVE A CONTROLLER IN YOUR
HANDS AS AN EXAMPLE.
SO ONCE AGAIN, WHEN WE REALLY
THINK ABOUT THECONTINUUM AND
IT'S OUR JOB TO PROO VID THE
BEST POSSIBLE FOR SO THEY
DELIVER ON THAT VISION.
>> SO GOD.
SO GOOD.
I WANT TO TAKE THAT AND I WANT
TO TURN THE QUESTION A LITTLE
BIT AND LET'S GO OVER TO YOU,
RACHEL.
THIS WEEK, THERE IS A LOT OF
NEWS COMING OUT FROM GAMING
COMPANIES.
AND THINKING AN ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
ARE POSITIONING HARDWARE AND
CLOUD PLATFORMS IS STARTING TO
FEEL LIKE THE STORY IS BECOMING
AN EITHER OR NARRATIVE.
IN 2020, MICROSOFT WILL RELEASE
PROJECT X CLOUD AND PROJECT
SERIOUS X.
WHAT IS MICROSOFT'S THINKING ON
THAT?
>> I'M HAPPY TO.
GAMERS AND DEVELOPERS ARE TRULY
AT THE CENTER OF EVERYTHING WE
DO.
AND FOR GAMERS, OUR VISION IS TO
BE ABLE TO PLAY THE GAMES YOU
WANT, WITH THE PEOPLE THEY WANT,
WHEREVER THEY WANT.
AND THE PARTNERS AND DEVELOPERS
ARE E KEY TO THE GOAL WE HAVE.
SO WE ARE TAKING OUR CUES FROM
GAMERS, FROM DEVELOPERS AND
KATHERINE MENTIONED, IT'S
VALUABLE TO GET THE LEARNINGS
AND BE LEARNING ABOUT THAT.
WE KNOW KNOW THAT GAMERS WANTS
MORE GAMES, THEY ARE PLAYING
WITH MORE PEOPLE AND PLAY ARE
PLAYING ON MORE DEVICE US AROUND
THE WORLD AND WE KNOW THAT
DEVELOPERS ARE TRYING TO REACH
NOR GAMERS AROUND THE WORLD AND
PLAYING ON MORE PLATFORMS.
THE XBOX SERIES X IS GUILT FOR
GAMERS ON MULTIPLE DEVICES AND
THE THING WE ARE E SEEING WITH
TECHNOLOGY CONVERGING AGAINST
CONSOLE, XC AND CLOUD.
WE WANT THEM TO FEEL UNCON
TRAINED AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
DEVELOPERS TO UNLUCK THE --
UNLOCK THE POTENTIAL AND SPIFX
FRIDAY FROM A DEVELOPER
PERSPECTIVE, JASON TALKED ON IT,
WE ARE REALLY AIMING TO BUILD
HARDWARE AND UNLEECH THE
CREATIVE VISION.
WE ARE EMPOWERING THEM TO CREATE
HOW THEY WANT BECAUSE THIGH KNOW
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM.
WE ARE PROVIDING THE TOOLS THEY
NEED FOR NOW AND FOR THE FUTURE.
THIS ENABLES THEM TO GET THE
GAMES TO MORE GAMERS AROUND THE
WORLD TO MORE XBOX GAMERS AROUND
THE WORLD.
WHETHER THEY ARE PLAYING ON CP,
O CLOUD.
I THINK IT SUMS IT UP, THE
QUESTION YOU ASK ABOUT EITHER
OR.
THE E APPEARANCE THAT IS
DESIGNED FROM DAY ONE SO IT'S
BETTER TOGETHER.
I THINK YOU ARE SAYING THE
PHILOSOPHY IS AND/OR, IT'S NOT
AN OR.
WE WILL LEAD WITH EXPERIENCE
WITH THE NEXT GEN CONSOLE.
>> YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT IS
SUPER IMPORTANT.
THE IDEA OF BETTER TOGETHER.
THAT IS A THEME WITHIN JUST
MICROSOFT AND GAME STACK.
THE IDEA IT'S NOT AN OR SAME BUT
AN AND STATEMENT.
AND GETTING THEM BRING IN THE
TOOLS AND THE THINGS THEY LOVE.
I REALLY LIKE THAT.
I'M CURIOUS, THE IDEA OF BETTER
TOGETHER.
WORKING ON PROJECT X CLOUD AND
XBOX SERIES KPX, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M SO PLEASED YOU CALLED ON ME,
BRIAN.
I WAS DYING TO ADD ONE THING TO
WHAT RACHEL SAID, WHICH IS SO
PERFECT.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THIS IDEA OF
CHOICE.
PLAYING YOUR GAMES WHEREVER YOU
CHOOSE TO PLAY THEM.
AND WE JUST HAVE SUCH A GREAT
STORY COME IN THE OTHER WEEK
FROM ONE OF THE PREVIEW TESTERS.
HE IS IN THE ARMED FORCES AND
CURRENTLY DEPLOYED.
HE COULDN'T TAKE HIS XBOX WITH
HIM BUT HE GETS TO PLAY DESTINY
2 THROUGH THE XBOX PREVIEW.
I THINK THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT AND REALLY SPEAKS TO
REACHING PEOPLE WHEREVER THEY
ARE.
AND I WANT TO GO TO THE ONE
POINT FURTHER WITH THAT.
BECAUSE WE TALKED EFRLIER
ABABOUT REACHING 2 BILLION
GAMERS, AND THAT DEMANDS BOTH
LOOKING TO THE XBOX WORLD AS WE
KNOW AND IT WHAT WE CALL TAM
EXPANSION.
THE TOTAL ADDRESSABLE MARKET
THAT WE CAN EXPAND TO.
AND WE NOW, ONE OF THE MARKETS
WE ARE COMING TO IS INDIA.
INDIA IS A HUGE GAMING NATION.
I READ THAT IT'S GOT THE FIFTH
MOST HIGHLY ENGAGED GAMER
POPULATION.
IT'S THEY DON'T KNOW SO WELL.
THAT IS FASCINATING AS WE WORK
WITH DEVELOPERS AND SAY, HOW CAN
WE BRING THE GRAEME GAMES WE ARE
BUILDING TO NEW MARKETS AND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES?
I REALLY THINK THAT FITTING WITH
THE BETTER TOGETHER.
THAT WE TAKE WHAT WE HAVE AND
BRING IT TO THE NEWS PLACES AND
NOW PEOPLE AND END POINTS.
IT COULD BEHIND A MORE EXCITING
TIME TO BE PART OF TEAM XBOX.
>> IT'S LIKE THERE IS A WORLD
WHERE IT'S ALL COMING TOGETHER.
AND CHRIS, I ALMOST WANT TO ASK
THE SAME QUESTION TO YOU, WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT FROM THEDY
SIGN PERSPECTIVE, BUILDING
BETTER TOGETHER, IT'S NOT SIMPLE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH SO
MANY END POINTS AND SO MANY
CUSTOMERS AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
GAMES.
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF DESIGN IN
THE IDEA OF THINKING ABOUT MULL
PL PRODUCTS, PLATFORMS AND
NETWORKS?
>> WELL, THE KATHERINE AND
RACHEL'S POINT ON CHOICE, WHEN
YOU THINK AFTER PLAYER
PERSPECTIVE, PLAYERS LOVE GAMES,
WHAT DO THEY CHOOSE TO DO IF YOU
HAND THEM A TIME TRAVEL DEVICE?
HA IS WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU GIVE
SOMETHING A CELLULAR PHONE OR
SOMETHING THEY TAKE WITH THEM.
THEY CANNOT ALWAYS
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT TO DO,
BAR ALL ELSE.
AND WHEN THEY FIND THEMSELVES,
YOU KNOW, PHYSICALLY STANDING IN
A LINE SOMEWHERE FOR FIVE
MINUTES, THREE MINUTES, TWO
HOURS, HOWEVER LONG IT'S GOING
TO BE, THEIR MIND IS OFTEN ON
THAT GAME.
AND WHAT BETTER THAN TO HAVE
THEIR MIND ON THAT GAME THAN TO
GIVE THEM THAT WORM HOLE SO THAT
THEY CAN SPEND THAT FIVE MINUTES
OR 15 MINUTES, WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE, INTERACTING WITH THE GAME
THEY WANT TO PLAY.
SOMETIMES THROUGH X-CLOUD IT'S
PLAYING IT.
SOMETIMES IT'S THROUGH THINGS
LIKE MIXER, WHAT THEY'RE DOING
TO WATCH IT.
IT'S DESIGN'S ROLE TO ALLOW
YOU -- SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO
PLAY, SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT GAME WITH YOUR
FRIENDS.
IF YOU WILL HAVE A DEVICE WITH
YOU OR AROUND YOU THROUGHOUT THE
DAY, WHAT ROLE DO THOSE DEVICES
SERVE AND DESIGN'S JOB IS TO
MAKE SURE IT'S HELPING PEOPLE
CONNECT TO THE CONTENT AND TO
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY WANT TO
PLAY THAT CONTENT WITH, AS OFTEN
AS THEY CAN, RIGHT?
AS OFTEN AS THEY CHOOSE TO.
BECAUSE THAT PLAYER CHOICE,
PHYSICALLY, IF I'M STANDING IN
THAT LINE AND CHECKED OUT, OKAY,
COOL.
I WANT TO PLAY A GAME, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT GAME.
IF YOU GIVE ME A FOUR-MINUTE
WINDOW TO DO IT, AMAZING, I'M
IN.
SO CERTAINLY ON THE DEVELOPER'S
SIDE, YOU THINK ABOUT WELL, HEY,
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BUILD
SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
PLAY FOR A SHORTER AMOUNT OF
TIME OR TO PLAY CONTINUOUSLY
THROUGHOUT THE DAY IN SMALL
SEGMENTS OF TIME, NOT JUST FOR
AN HOUR OR SIX HOURS THAT YOU'LL
SPEND SITTING IN FRONT OF YOUR
CONSELLOLE OR PC.
S HOW DO YOU GIVE PEOPLE THE
CHOICE TO PARTICIPATE?
THE THING THAT THEY LOVE MORE
OFF AND SHARE THAT WITH MORE
PEOPLE, AND CERTAINLY THAT WAS
THE GOAL THAT WE SET OUT TO
ACCOMPLISH AND BETTER TOGETHER
REALLY JUST MEANS BEING SUPER
ATTUNED TO LETTING GAMERS GET
CLOSER TO THE THING THAT THEY
LOVE.
>> YOU KNOW, I WANT TO GIVE A
PLUG FOR SOME CONTENT WE HAD
THAT WAS PREDONE BEFORE THE SHOW
TAPED.
IT WAS THIS X-CLOUD TALK THAT WE
HAVE UP ON THE ON DEMAND SITE.
SO IF YOU GO TO THE WEBSITE AND
YOU CHECK OUT SOME OF THE
X-CLOUD CONTEMPT ON THE YOUTUBE
PAGE, THERE'S SOME FASCINATING
STUFF GOING ON AND HOW THEY
THINK ABOUT BUILDING FOR THE
PLATFORM
CHRIS, I WANT TO ASK A QUICK
FOLLOW-UP.
WITH REGARDS TO DESIGN ITSELF,
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WHEN TRYING TO DESIGN A UI OR UX
THAT CAN MAP ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEVICES?
>> UH, THERE'S A LOT.
FOR THE USER, I MEAN, THERE'S
LITERALLY LIKE HEY, WHAT'S THE
TYPE RAMP AND HOW DO YOU MAKE IT
WORK IN MULTIPLE LOCATIONS,
WHETHER THE ANGULAR PIXEL
DENSITY IS DIFFERENT, THERE'S A
BUNCH OF TECHNICAL DETAILS
RELATED TO DESIGN.
BUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
THERE TO HELP CONNECT YOU.'S -
SO THE THING THAT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE IN TERMS OF HEY, I
WANT TO PLAY RIGHT NOW, AND THIS
IS HOW I WANT TO INTERACT WITH
THE GAME I LOVE, IS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND YOU
MIGHT WANT TO PRESENT MORE OF A
SOCIAL VIEW INTO THAT THING WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT ON A CELL
PHONE IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE THING
THAT SETS YOU UP TO PLAY LATER
IN DEPTH WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
WHEN WE TALK TO GAMERS, YOU
KNOW, THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT
THEY SAY IS HEY, I WISH I COULD
SPEND MORE TIME GAMING, I JUST
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME.
IT'S EVEN HARDER FOR ME TO FIND
CROSSOVER TIME WITH MY FRIENDS
TO PLAY TOGETHER, RIGHT?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT THEY
WOULD LOVE HELP SOLVING.
SO FROM A UI PERSPECTIVE,
THERE'S LITERALLY, HOW DO YOU
MAKE THIS UI LOOK GOOD ON A
DIFFERENT END POINT AND WHAT DO
I NEED TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FROM
A DESIGN PERSPECTIVE?
IT'S ALSO WHAT SHOULD I BE
SHOWCASING TO THE USER?
BECAUSE IT MIGHT NOT BE THEY
WANT TO PLAY RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
CAT RISING A GROUP TO GET
TOGETHER TO PLAY LATER TONIGHT.
SO HAVING YOUR UI HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT A PLAYER HAS
BEEN DOING ACROSS YOUR GAME IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN SHOWCASE THAT
EVEN WITHIN THE GAME.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET ON
LATER TONIGHT OR THIS WEEKEND?
THOSE ARE TWO INDEPENDENT
THINGS, BUT THEY'RE VERY MUCH
BOTH IN DESIGN'S WHEEL HOUSE TO
TRY AND FIX.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
ECOSYSTEM THAT YOU'RE ATTACHED
TO MOVING FORWARD, DESIGN IS
GOING TO BE INCREASINGLY FOCUSED
ON HOW DO I GET PLAYERS ACCESS
TO THE RIGHT THING AT THE RIGHT
TIME AT THE RIGHT MOMENT?
BECAUSE CERTAINLY OUR JOB IS TO
TAKE CARE OF THINGS LIKE THE
TYPE RAMP SO THAT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW, FONTS ON A
CELL PHONE, WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
STREAMED, THAT THEY ARE AS
APPROPRIATE THERE AS THEY ARE ON
A TEN-FOOT SCREEN.
THAT'S JUST STUFF WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF.
>> AWESOME.
GO A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO OUR N-
JOURNEY WITH DEVELOPERS.
JASON, THIS IS A QUESTION FOR
YOU.
GIVEN THIS IS A YEAR WE'RE
SHIPPING A CONSOLE AND A
STREAMING PLATFORM, I'M CURIOUS,
JASON, WHAT IS THE APPROACH
MICROSOFT HAS TAKEN IN THE
JOURNEY WITH WORKING WITH GAPE
DEVELOPERS?
AND KACATHERINE, WE'RE GOING AS
YOU THE SAME QUESTION.
>> IT'S FUNNY, BECAUSE CATHERINE
AND I OFTEN DO THIS TOGETHER.
BECAUSE WE REALLY DON'T TALK TO
OR ENGAGE WITH DEVELOPERS, JUST
ON CONSOLE OR PROJECT X-CLOUD OR
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH PC AS AN
EXAMPLE.
WE'VE TALKED TO DEVELOPERS, AND
LAY OUT OUR VISION FOR THE
FUTURE.
AND HOW WE CAN HELP THEM DELIVER
ON THE EXPERIENCES THAT THEY
WANT TO PROVIDE TO THEIR
PLAYERS.
SO THAT MEANS A CONSISTENT
HARDWARE PLATFORM BETWEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CONSOLE
ECOSYSTEM, AND SOMEWHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE GAME STREAMING
SIDE.
IT'S A COMMON SOFTWARE PLATFORM,
COMMON EPIs.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE CODE
THE GAME DEVELOPERS WRITE SHOULD
BE REUSABLE ACROSS THE CLOUD,
ACROSS THE CONSOLE, ACROSS PC.
SO AS WE UPDATED OUR DESIGNS AND
OUR AN MODEL, WE DESIGNED TO
MAKE IT WORK ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEVICES.
WHERE WE WANT DEVELOPERS TO
FOCUS THEIR TIME IS MAKING THE
GAME EXPERIENCE GREAT SO THAT
PLAYERS HAVE A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
AND REALLY TAILORING IT TO THE
UNIQUE CAPABILITIES OF HOW THEY
CHOOSE TO DELIVER IT.
YOU KNOW, SIMPLE THINGS SUCH AS
IF I'M PLAYING ON A CONSOLE,
CLEARLY I'M GOING TO LEAD WITH
CONTROLLER BASED INPUT.
IF THE SAME GAME IS BEING PLAYED
ON A PC, KEYBOARD MOUSE IS
IMPORTANT, OR MAYBE IT'S MORE
ABOUT TOUCH CONTROLS OR MAKING
IT EASIER FOR A PLAYER TO PLAY
THERE.
SO IT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS FOR ME OVER THE LAST
THREE TO FOUR YEARS, IS AS WE'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING THESE THINGS, AS
WE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGING THE
TEAMS INTERNALLY ON THIS NEXT
GENERATION AND HOW WE THINK
ABOUT GAMING AND GAME
DEVELOPMENT IS GOING OUT AND
TALKING TO THE PARTNERS AND, YOU
KNOW, HEARING THEIR FEEDBACK.
YOU KNOW, TELLING THEM HERE'S
WHERE WE SEE THINGS ARE GOING.
GETTING THE FEEDBACK FROM THEM.
AND ADJUSTING AND ALTERING OUR
PLANS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE ALL
JUST WANT THOSE SAME GREAT
GAMING EXPERIENCES.
AS RACHEL AND CHRIS AND
CATHERINE HAVE SAID, IT'S REALLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
PLAYERS ALL ACROSS THE WORLD CAN
HAVE THESE SAME GREAT GAMING
EXPERIENCES.
AND DO IT IN SUCH A WAY WE MAKE
IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPERS.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT WAS
INTERESTING ABOUT WORKING WITH
DEVELOPERS.
IT'S THIS IDEA OF WE HAVE ALL
THESE DEVELOPERS WHO ARE COMING
AND WATCHING, AND ARE
PARTICIPATING IN A CHANNEL.
FOLLOWING US ON TWITTER.
FOR FOLKS NOT WORKING WITH
MICROSOFT TODAY AND THINKING
ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
HARDWARE AND STREAMING, WHAT ARE
SOME ADVICE, SOME TIPS THAT YOU
GIVE IN HEY, THIS IS WHAT WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED IN WORKING WITH
GAME DEVELOPERS AND HERE ARE
SOME IDEAS HOW TO THINK ABOUT
THAT.
JASON, TO YOU, AND THEN
CATHERINE OVER TO YOU.
>> SURE.
JUST KEEP BUILDING GAMES THE WAY
THAT YOU ALWAYS HAVE BEEN
BUILDING GAMES.
IF YOU'RE BUILDING A GAME ON PC
TODAY, WE HAVE MADE IT VERY EASY
TO MAKE A PC CODE BASED AND
GETTING IT RUNNING IN THE CLOUD.
WE PARTNER CLOSELY WITH ALL THE
INDUSTRIES, LEADING MIDDLE WARE
AND ENGINE PROVIDERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE OPTIMIZED TO
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF WHAT WE
DELIVER, WHETHER IT'S HARDWARE
CAPABILITIES OR SOME OF THE
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE WITH X-BOX
LIVE AND AZURE PLAY FAB.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THE -- THE PART THAT'S REALLY
EXCITING ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY AND
PART OF THE REASON WHY I LOVE
THIS INDUSTRY, IT'S THE MARRYING
OF CREATIVITY AND TECHNOLOGY.
THAT'S THE THING THAT THE GAME
DEVELOPERS ALL ACROSS THE WORLD,
WHETHER IT'S THE LARGEST WORKING
ON A AAA BLOCKBUSTER, OR SMALL,
INDEPENDENT CREATORS, IT'S ABOUT
THE WORLDS YOU WANT TO CREATE
AND THE EXPERIENCES YOU WANT TO
DELIVER TO PLAYERS.
IT'S OUR JOB AT TEAM X-BOX TO
REMOVE THE TECHNOLOGY AND MAKE
THE TECHNOLOGY FADE AWAY IN THE
BACKGROUND.
DEVELOPERS ARE JUST FOCUSED ON
CREATING THAT IE HER SAVE
EXPERIENCE.
>> CATHERINE, WHAT ARE YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND THOUGHTS ON HOW
A GAME DEVELOPER SHOULD THINK
ABOUT BUILDING FOR THIS NEXT
GENERATION HARDWARE, BUILDING
FOR THIS NEXT GENERATION OF
STREAMING?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I'M JUST
GOING TO STOP.
JASON SAID IT SO BEAUTIFULLY, WE
OFTEN GO OUT TOGETHER.
AND EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
HAPPENS.
JASON SAID IT SO BEAUTIFULLY.
I JUST NEED TO GO, IT'S WHAT HE
SAID.
BUT I'LL TRY TO ADD TO THAT.
YOU KNOW, AS WE TALKED 5 E
E
BEFORE, THE CONVENIENCE OF
DEVELOPING FOR THE XBOX THAT
MAGICALLY WORKS IN THE CLOUD.
THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP.
JASON TOOK US THROUGH IT EARLIER
AND TALKED TO SOME OF THE TOUCH
CONTROLS AND APIs WE'RE BUILDING
AROUND TO PROVIDING MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER THE
GAME IS STREAMING.
THAT HAS BEEN THE NEXT PIECE,
WHICH IS THE CLOUD AWARE PIECE.
THE IMPORTANT POINT THAT WE
HAVEN'T TOUCHED ON IS FAR,
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY THINKING
ABOUT, THIS CONCEPT OF WHAT
WE'RE CALLING CLOUD NATIVE
GAMES, GAMES THAT NO LONGER JUST
USE THE SOURCESF THE LOCAL
DEVICE, BUT HARNESS THE FULL
POWER OF THE CLOUD.
IT'S SO FASCINATING.
BEFORE THE WORLD GOT STOPPED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS, I HAD AN
INCREDIBLE TRIP TO JAPAN AND
KOREA MEETING WITH DEVELOPERS.
YOU KNOW, SO FASCINATING TO SEE
HOW PEOPLE WERE LEANING IN TO
REALLY UNDERSTANDING HOW THE
CLOUD COULD CHANGE THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPMENT.
THE ITERATION OF DEVELOPMENT, AS
WELL AS -- I THINK IT WAS CHRIS
WHO MENTIONED IT EARLIER.
THIS IDEA OF FRICTIONLESS PLAY
AND WHAT IT MEANT FOR THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO COULD PLAY
TOGETHER OR SOME OF THE BUSINESS
MODELS.
AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY SEEING
HERE IS CREATIVITY UNLEASHED.
YOU KNOW, AS JASON JUST SAID,
IT'S OUR JOB TO PUT THE
TECHNOLOGY BEHIND SO OTHERS CAN
JUST LEVERAGE IT.
AND OUR VISION IS FOR DEVELOPERS
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THE CLOUD.
AND WE'RE NOT JUST SEEING THIS
EXCITEMENT WITH SOME OF OUR
OTHER DEVELOPERS.
IT'S INCREDIBLE THE SUPPORT
WE'VE HAD FROM THE XBOX PROGRAM.
AND OUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
DEVELOPERS IS REALLY CLEAR, WE
JUST WANT YOU TO FOCUS ON YOUR
GAMES AND YOUR GAME PLAY.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT PUTTING IT TO
OTHER PLATFORMS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT, BETWEEN THE CONSOLE AND
THE CLOUD, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THAT FOR YOU.
SO THAT'S WHAT I THINK IS SO
EXCITING ABOUT THIS PERIOD.
AND THAT'S THE ENERGY WE GET AS
WE MEET WITH DEVELOPERS IS THAT
THIS PERIOD IS ABOUT LITERALLY
THIS UNLEASHING OF CREATIVITY.
AND THAT CAN ONLY BE GREAT FOR
GAMERS.
>> SO SOMETHING THAT NOT A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF MICROSOFT
GET A CHANCE TO HEAR, SOME OF
THE PHILOSOPHIES BEHIND WHY
WE'RE DOING THIS, CATHERINE, CAN
YOU TOUCH ON JUST FOR A SECOND
WHERE DO WE SEE THIS ALL GOING?
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HOW WE WANT
TO PUT THE GAMER AT THE CENTER,
MAKE SURE THEY CAN PLAY THE
GAMES THEY WANT, FOR THE PEOPLE
THEY WANT.
HOW DOES THIS ALL KIND OF PLAY
INTO THE LARGER MISSION AT
MICROSOFT?
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN
SPEAK TO THE LARGER MISSION OF
MICROSOFT, BUT I CAN SPEAK TO
HOW WE VIEW THE MISSION AS A
TEAM.
IT'S ALL ABOUT UBIQUITY.
YOUR GAME SHOULD BE ABLE TO PLAY
ON ANY DEVICE AT ANY POINT YOU
CHOOSE TO PLAY.
AND THE COMMUNITY AND ALL YOUR
SAVES AND EVERYTHING ELSE
RELATED TO THE GAME JUST COMES
WITH YOU.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT IT.
WE'VE SEEN THIS IN VIDEO.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN WATCH YOUR
NETFLIX.
I PERSONALLY CHOOSE TO WATCH
MOST OF MY MOVIES ON MY PHONE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN WATCH IT
ON ANY DEVICE THAT YOU CHOOSE.
AND I REALLY THINK THIS CONCEPT
OF UBIQUITY IS KEY.
IT'S ABOUT REACHING EVERY
PLATFORM AND IT'S ABOUT US, YOU
KNOW, FOR DEVELOPERS, AS I SAID
BEFORE, REALLY LEVERAGING THE
CLOUD AND THROUGH OUR PARTNERS
WITH AZURE, WHICH IS AS WE KNOW
ONE OF THE WORLD'S LEADING
CLOUDS WITH THE HUGE
GEOGRAPHICAL FOOT PRINT, TO
ALLOW US TO REACH GAMERS WHO
PREVIOUSLY, IT WAS MUCH HARDER
FOR US TO REACH WITH THIS
FIDELITY OF GAME.
SO THAT'S REALLY OUR VISION.
> THAT'S GOOD.
IN TALKING WITH A LOT OF THE
DEVELOPERS, ESPECIALLY AS THEY
ARE STARTING TO GET TO THE NEXT
STAGE, ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT NECESSARILY ENGAGED WITH
MICROSOFT TODAY AROUND XBOX
SERIES OR PROJECT CLOUD, RACHEL,
IF YOU COULD ANSWER, WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY TO A DEVELOPER WHO IS
LOOKING AT THIS TECHNOLOGY
SAYING I DON'T KNOW, WHEN IS THE
RIGHT TIME TO GET INVOLVED?
>> I THINK IT'S A LOT WHAT
CATHERINE AND JASON TALKED ON.
JUMP IN, RIGHT?
I THINK BACK TO WHEN WE STARTED
OUR GAMES, IT SEEMS LIKE
LIFETIME AGO, THERE WAS THREE OF
US.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WE DIDN'T
KNOW.
AND THAT ENABLED US TO DO REALLY
AWESOME THINGS.
AND FOR US AT TEAM XBOX, YOU
KNOW, WE TRULY LOVE HEARING
THOSE IDEAS AND SEEING WHAT
DEVELOPERS CAN CREATE, BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT
TO DO.
YOU'RE GOING TO TELL US, RIGHT?
AND SO IF I PUT MYSELF IN MY OWN
SHOES A LONG TIME AGO, I THINK
IT WOULD BE, JUST JUMP IN.
WORK WITH US.
REACH OUT TO US.
HELP US LEARN WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW, HELP US FIGURE THAT OUT TO
REDUCE THAT FRICTION, TO DELIVER
THOSE CREATIVE VISIONS.
ESPECIALLY AS WE THINK ABOUT
DEVELOPING FOR BOTH CONSOLE AND
CLOUD, THE CLOUD SPACE IS SO
EXCITING.
I DON'T THINK WE EVEN KNOW WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
I ALWAYS TALKED TO THE TEAM
ABOUT WATCHING MY CHILDREN PLAY.
THEY PLAY TOGETHER.
THEY'RE ON MULTIPLE DEVICES.
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY GOING BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN DEVICES.
AND IT'S WHERE THEIR FRIENDS ARE
AND WHERE THEY GO.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY ACROSS THESE
PLATFORMS AND DEVICES, THAT'S
WHAT XBOX WANTS TO BRING TO
DEVELOPERS, THE ABILITY TO REACH
GAMERS WHERE WE SEE THEM GOING.
SO JUMP IN.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
SO LET'S TALK REAL QUICK ABOUT
SOME OF THE KEY LEARNINGS THAT
WE HAVE GOTTEN FROM DEVELOPMENT
PARTNERS DURING THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE DONE TO BUILD OUR XBOX
SERIES.
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR WHAT IS GOING
WELL.
WHAT ARE SOME CHALLENGES PEOPLE
HAVE BUILDING FOR THE CLOUD AND
FOR NEW TECHNOLOGY?
JASON, LET'S GO TO YOU.
>> SURE.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
EXCITING ABOUT THE TRANSITION OF
A GENERATION IS WHAT YOU USED TO
THINK OF PREVIOUSLY AS
CONSTRAINTS, MANY TIMES THEY GO
AWAY.
I MENTIONED THE FACT THAT WE'RE
AT THE UPPER BOUNDS OF WHAT'S
POSSIBLE WITH THE ROTATIONAL
DRIVE.
NOW THAT'S NO LONGER A BARRIER,
IT OPENS UP ALL THESE NEW
POSSIBILITIES.
BUT THEN WE'RE GOING TO DISCOVER
SOME OF THE NEXT CHALLENGES.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE NOW I HAVE
ALMOST KIND OF UNLIMITED MEMORY
AND I CAN FEED IT INTO THE
SYSTEM.
BUT NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS WE PREVIOUSLY
COUNTED ON NO LONGER EXIST.
I THINK THAT CHALLENGES A LOT OF
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS.
SO I THINK THERE'S THAT.
I THINK THE OTHER THING TOO IS
JUST, YOU KNOW, THERE'S TIMES
WHERE THERE'S A MEMBER OF THE
TEAM WHO SHE MENTIONED, YOU
KNOW, WITH XBOX 1-X, IT WAS LIKE
GETTING A PLAYGROUND TO PLAY
WITH.
WITH SOMETHING LIKE XBOX SERIES
X, NOW THE ENTIRE TEAM HAS AN
AMUSEMENT PARK TO PLAY WITH.
SO IT CAN BE OVERWHELMING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE DO I WANT TO
INVEST?
WHAT ARE THESE NEW OPPORTUNITIES
I HAVE?
SO I THINK THE REAL GUIDANCE I
GIVE TO DEVELOPERS IN THE
COMMUNITY OUT THERE IS, YOU
KNOW, CHALLENGE YOURSELVES,
THINK CREATIVELY.
WHAT IS THE GAMING EXPERIENCE
YOU ALWAYS WANTED TO BUILD?
AND A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THROUGHOUT TODAY,
IF THERE'S EVER SOMETHING WHERE
THE SOFTWARE IS NOT ABLING YOU
TO DO IT, OR THE DEVELOPMENT
TOOLS WOULD BE MORE USEFUL IF
THEY DID THIS, OR MY ITERATION
TIME NEEDS TO IMPROVE, WE WANT
THAT FEEDBACK.
WE NEED THAT FEEDBACK.
WE LISTEN TO THAT FEEDBACK, AND
IT FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFTS THE
DIRECTION THAT WE GO.
SO WE LISTEN VERY CLOSELY TO THE
GAMING COMMUNITY.
WE'RE ALL GAMERS OURSELVES, WE
ALL PLAY ON XBOX OURSELVES.
WE HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT WE
CONNECT WITH.
IT'S ALSO TRUE WITH DEVELOPERS,
AS WELL.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHERE WE HAVE
GOTTEN IT RIGHT AND WHERE YOU'RE
STRUGGLING.
OUR CHALLENGE IS TO TAKE THAT
FEEDBACK AND TO GO AWAY AND TO
COME UP WITH CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY, SO YOU
CAN FOCUS ON DELIVERING THAT
AMAZING GAMING EXPERIENCE, THAT
ALL OF US CAN'T WAIT TO PLAY.
>> THAT'S SO GOOD.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING TIGHT ON
TIME.
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
LIGHTNING ROUND.
WE HAVE A SET OF QUESTIONS WE'RE
GOING TO ASK EVERY PERSON HERE.
WHAT ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS FOR A GAME DEVELOPER TO
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY.
RACHEL, LET'S START WITH YOU.
>> OKAY.
I'LL TRY TO BE SUPER QUICK SINCE
WE'RE TIGHT ON TIME.
I THINK MY HOPE IS THAT THE
BIGGEST -- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
TAKE AWAYS FROM TODAY IS A
FEELING OF EXCITEMENT.
AS WE MENTIONED, WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF SOMETHING VERY CRAZY,
UNPRECEDENTED GOING ON IN THE
WORLD.
THERE'S A LOT OF HEAVINESS.
I HOPE THAT ANYBODY LISTENING,
WHETHER IT WAS A DEVELOPER, A
GAMER, MAYBE A STUDENT, WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING REMOTE
LEARNING, THAT THEY FEEL THAT
LIGHT INSIDE OF THEM, THAT THEY
FEEL THAT PASSION WE ALL HAVE
FOR GAMING.
I HOPE THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
FUT
EXCITED ABOUT, YOU KNOW, HOW WE
CAN DO THINGS TOGETHER AND THE
THINGS WE'RE GOING TO BUILD
TOGETHER TO REACH GAMERS AROUND
THE WORLD SO THAT THEY CAN PLAY
WATCH, COMMUNICATE AND CREATE
TOGETHER.
THAT'S GOOD.
CHRIS, LET'S GO OVER TO YOU,
WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
A GAPME DEVELOPER SHOULD TAKE
AWAY FROM THIS CONVERSATION?
>> I WAS HOPING TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IN RELATION
TO INPUT AND SKILL CEILING.
YOU TELL EVERYBODY HEY, WE'RE
GOING TO PACK A STADIUM FOR
PEOPLE TO WATCH TICKTACKTOE,
THAT WOULDN'T BE THE CASE,
BECAUSE THE WORLD CHAMPIONSHIP
OF TICKTACKTOE IS GOING TO BE
BORING, BECAUSE THERE'S NO SKILL
CEILING BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS A
TIE.
AS WE HAVE GONE DOWN THIS ROUTE
AND LOOKED AT WHAT THE NEW
GENERATION OF PEOPLE GROWING UP,
LEARNING HOW TO USE, YOU KNOW,
PLAY GAMES ON GLASS NATIVELY,
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN HOW I
GREW UP WITH THE CONTROLLER,
PEOPLE CAN PLAY GAMES ON GLASS
TO A DEGREE AND A FIDELITY WHICH
ALLOWS A SKILL CEILING, WHICH IS
INCREDIBLE.
IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO WHEN WE
KICKED OFF OUR JOURNEY LOOKING
AT THAT.
I DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS GOING TO
BE THE CASE.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT
IT ON THE CUSTOMER SIDE AND WITH
THE BEST GAME DEVELOPERS ON THE
PLANET ARE DOING, PEOPLE ARE
REALLY SOLVING THE SKILL
PROBLEM -- THE SKILL CEILING
PROBLEM.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT PUSHING
A GAME OUT, I WOULD NOT BE
WORRIED ABOUT THINKING ABOUT A
PHONE PERHAPS AS THE LOWEST
COMMON DENOMINATOR.
BE CONFIDENT THAT YOU CAN MAKE
THE GAME YOU'VE BUILT, YOU'RE
THINKING OF A PCR CONSOLE.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT SKILL CEILING,
YOU CAN MAKE THAT THING
EXCELLENT NO MATTER WHERE IT'S
BEING STREAMED TO.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
CATHERINE, WHAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING A DEVELOPER CAN
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY?
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS EMBRACE THE
NEW, BE OPEN TO LEARNING, AND
DON'T CONSTRAIN YOUR THINKING
ABOUT FRAMEWORKS THAT HAVE
EXISTED IN GAMING PREVIOUSLY.
I THINK WE'RE IN A PERIOD WHERE
WE ARE REWRITING THE RULES OF
TRADITIONAL GAME DEVELOPMENT.
AND I THINK THAT'S SUCH AN
EXCITING PERIOD WITH HUGE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN
REALLY, YOU KNOW, LEVERAGE THAT
IS BY BEING OPEN TO ANY AMOUNT
OF POSSIBILITIES, AND JUST
INCREASING THOSE LEARNING
CYCLES.
SO BE OPEN TO THE NEW.
THAT'S MY MAIN TAKE AWAY.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
AND JASON, WHAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING A DEVELOPER CAN
TAKE AWAY FROM TODAY'S
CNVERSATION?
>> IT'S KIND OF FUNNY.
EVERYBODY ELSE SAID IT SO
ELOQUENTLY, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH MORE I CAN ADD.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO
WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TALKED
ABOUT IS, JUST FOCUS ON THE
PLAYER, FOCUS ON THE GAMER.
JUST REALLY FOCUS ON HOW CAN YOU
DELIGHT THAT PLAYER?
YOU KNOW, THE NEED TO PLAY IS
JUST A FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
CONDITION.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK MANY OF
US WORK IN THIS INDUSTRY AND WE
LOVE THIS INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
OUR JOB IS TO CREATE FUN AND
THERE'S NOTHING BETTER TO DO.
AND SO AS LONG AS YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON THE PLAYER, WE'RE
HERE TO HELP IN ANY WAY THAT WE
CAN.
WE WANT THE FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY, BOTH PLAYERS AND
DEVELOPERS.
BUT AS LONG AS YOU'RE FOCUSING
ON THE PLAYER, I DON'T THINK YOU
CAN GO WRONG.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
SO GOOD.
WELL, THANK YOU GUYS SO VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US OVER THE
PHONE.
IT HAS BEEN AN AWESOME CHANCE TO
TALK WITH YOU.
THAT'S IT FOR US.
KELLY, OVER TO YOU.
>> YOU TOOK THE CONSOLE.
ANY WAY, THANKS, BRIAN.
KELLY, IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT NEXT GEN HARDWARE AND
WHAT IT CAN DO, WE CAN CROSS
THAT OFF THE LIST.
>> I COULD NOT BE MORE XOOEXCIT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THIS IS AN EXCITING PERIOD OF
TIME.
NEXT GEN HARDWARE COMING OUT
THIS YEAR.
>> ANY WAY, XBOX SERIES X.
SO EVERYONE OUT THERE, GO TO OUR
DISCORD AND LET US KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT IT AND TELL US ABOUT
ALL OF THE THING S.
IN ANY EVENT, WE HAVE SOME TEAMS
FROM OUR -- SOME OF OUR FAVORIE
GAMES IN CHAT, AS WELL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
LIKE AGE OF EMPIRES, I'M SO
EXCITED.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE GAME OF ALL
TIME.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
IT'S A GREAT TIME.
IT CAUSED ME TO GET INTO GAMING
AND DO WHAT I DO RIGHT NOW.
OVER THE LAST TWO DAYS.
CONVERSATIONS WITH STUDIO
DIRECTORS, AND EVEN SOME IDEAS
OF XBOX PROS.
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR HIGHLIGHT?
>> I THINK I KIND OF GAVE IT
AWAY, THAT WAS THE MOST
EXCITING -- I THINK AGAIN, WE
SAID IT YESTERDAY, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE ALWAYS DREAMED
ABOUT IS BEING AT MICROSOFT
DURING THE LAUNCH OF A NEW
CONSOLE.
AND XBOX SERIES X COMING OUT
THIS YEAR IS GOING TO BE
FANTASTIC.
THE FOCUS ON PERFORMANCE, SPEED,
AND OF COURSE, COMPATIBILITY.
THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE THOUSANDS OF GAMES PLAYABLE
ON YOUR CONSOLE.
THE SSD, FIRST-EVER GENERATION
THAT WILL HAVE SSD BUILT INTO
THE CONSOLE.
AND JUST GP POWER.
SO YEAH, KELLY, WHAT WAS YOUR
HIGHLIGHT IF
>> I LIKE THE ACCESSIBILITY
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD YESTERDAY
AND JUST LEARNING ABOUT THE
SERVICES.
IT'S INCREDIBLE LEARNING WHAT
GAME STACK IS.
IF THERE'S ANY DEVELOPERS THAT
ARE JUST JOINING US, CHECK OUT
GAMESTACK.COM.
AND WE'LL HAVE AVAILABLE THE
TALKS AND PANELS OVER THE LAST
TWO DAYS.
SO DO NOT FRET, EVERYONE,
BECAUSE ALL THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE SOON.
>> WHO IS EVER TO SAY WHEN
SOMETHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
ONE THING I'VE LOVED OVER THE
LAST TWO DAYS IS TALKING TO YOU.
YOU SAID A LOT.
SO LET'S CHECK OUT WHAT YOU SAID
OUT HERE.
OUR LAST PANEL, PARTNER DIRECTOR
OF -- DUE TO TECHNICAL ISSUES,
WE HAD TO USE HEAD SHOTS AND
SOMEONE HAS TAKEN JASON'S AND
DOCTORED IT A BIT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
SO JASON, LET ME JUST SAY
SOMETHING.
JASON HAS ONE OF THE MOST
GLORIOUS BEARDS I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> IT REALLY IS.
EVEN THE LENGTH AND PATTERN OF
IT, LIKE HOW HALF IS GRAY, HALF
IS DARK.
WE HAVE THAT STRIP OF GRAY.
IT'S VERY --
>> VERY DELIBERATE AND VERY
REGAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE WORD WOULD
BE.
>> I LIKE REGAL.
>> IT'S REALLY COOL TO SEE.
HE'S JUST PERCHING OVER XBOX.
HE HAS PUT EVERYTHING TOGETHER,
ALONG WITH A GREAT TEAM.
SO THIS IS COOL TO SEE.
I THINK WE HAVE A FEW MORE
TWEETS.
>> I THINK THAT WAS TO SCALE,
THOUGH.
IT DOUBLES AS A HEATER FOR YOUR
HOUSE.
>> IT DOUBLES AS A LOT.
IT'S FUNNY, BECAUSE XBOX TWEETED
OUT A PICTURE ON MONDAY TO SCALE
AN XBOX CONSOLE NEXT TO A
FRIDGE.
SO IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
WE HAVE ANOTHER TWEET FROM AN
MVP.
THIS IS SIMON DARKSIDE.
IT SAYS MY FAVORITE QUOTE FROM
THE TEAM, LET'S LOOK BACK HERE.
MY FAVORITE QUOTE FROM THE TEAM
TODAY IS THIS, SOMETHING ELSE
YOU SHOULD KNOW, THE SAME TEAM
THAT SAW THE AMAZING TECHNICAL
FEAT OF XBOX 360 IS THE TEAM
THAT CREATED PROJECT X-CLOUD.
AWESOMENESS TO THE MAX.
100%.
SO JUST TO GIVE A NOTE ON THAT,
BACK IN 2015, WE ANNOUNCED XBOX
360 WITH COMPATIBILITY ON XBOX
ONE.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE LOTS OF
SOLUTIONS AND I'M SUPER EXCITED.
>> IT IS EXCITING, JUST HOW
GAMING AND DEVELOPMENT EVOLVES
EVERY GENERATION AND ITERATION.
SOMETHING NEW THEY ADD,
SOMETHING INCREDIBLE WITH THE
TEAMS WE HAVE HERE.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT OUR
FAVORITE PARTS OF TODAY.
MY FAVORITE PART MIGHT BE THE
NEXT CONVERSATION YOU'LL BE
HAVING.
OF COURSE, I THINK BRUTAL LEGEND
DOES NOT GET AS MUCH LOVE AS IT
DESERVES.
LET'S GO BACK ON TOUR HERE.
HEY, NEW CHAPTER, THE EVOLUTION.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS SAYING.
THANK YOU.
AND IS THAT A BOT?
>> LOVE THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> DID RICARD PAY TO GETTIS
TWEET UP HERE?
>> I THINK SO.
ALTHOUGH IT IS REALLY COOL, THE
SHOES WITH THE SHIRT.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
YESTERDAY HEARD THAT SOME PEOPLE
WERE ASKING HOW DO WE GET THESE
SHIRTS, HOW DO I GET THIS
JACKET?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> DOES KELLY HAVE AN ANSWER?
>> IF YOU COMPLAIN ENOUGH,
SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN.
>> RICARD, I HEARD IT IN MY EAR
THAT RICARD DID PAY FOR THIS
FREE PROMOTION.
IN WHICH CASE I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW HOW MUCH THAT COSTS.
ANY WAY.
>> EVERYONE, NOW IT'S TIME TO
CHECK OUT ONE OF THE MOST
CREATIVE ECOSYSTEMS IN THE
GAMING INDUSTRY THAT'S HELPED
PROPEL A DEATH TEAM TO GAMING
GLORY.
>> BEFORE MAKING A LIST OF
PRIORITIES FOR THE COMPANY, THE
TOP OF THE LIST WOULD BE
CREATIVITY.
WHETHER IT'S OUR BUSINESS OR I
DON'T WANT TO SAY CREATIVE
FINANCES.
THAT PROBABLY SOUNDS BAD.
♪ ♪
>> A GAME SHOULD.
JUST BE ONE PERSON'S VISION.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING IN A FUN PROJECT THAT
WILL APPEAL TO A VERY WIDE
VARIETY OF PEOPLE, BECAUSE WE
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY OF PEOPLE
MAKING THAT CONTENT HERE.
THAT'S JUST WHAT MAKES OUR
GAMING SPECIAL.
>> THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE MADE
THAT LEADS TO A UNIQUE FEELING
IN OUR GAMES.
>> THINKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX,
ACCESS TO A COUNTERCULTURE YOU
MAY NOT SEE IN GAMES.
PEOPLE COME TO PLAY GAMES THAT
ARE DIFFERENT AND UNIQUE.
>> I STARTED THE COMPANY BECAUSE
I HAD AN IDEA FOR A GAME.
IT STRUCK ME AT A CERTAIN POINT
THAT DOING MY IDEAS FOR TEN
YEARS.
THERE WAS SO MANY CREATIVE
PEOPLE AT THE COMPANY, HOW DO WE
GET EVERYBODY'S IDEAS TO THE
FOREFRONT?
SO WE TOOK A BREAK AND WE SPLIT
THE WHOLE COMPANY, 60 PEOPLE
INTO FOUR SMALLER TEAMS, WHICH
SEEMED CRAZY AT THE TIME.
FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE GOING TO
STOP WORKING ON THIS GAME, WHICH
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A GAME IN
TWO WEEKS.